hello
welcome my name is rudolf jeremiah i
came here from tbilisi georgia
let me briefly introduce myself in 2016
i joined georgian startup pulsar ai
where we created first georgian chatbot
framework
for virtual framework for georgian
language which later integrated
in mobile bank system
and also it was used by different
companies in georgia i also worked on
different machine learning tools like
sentiment analysis tool or
news
clustering and after two years working
as a machine learning engineer i
switched to data st to data engineering
and i joined toptel
in 2018 and started working on data
engineering projects and implement
implemented infrastructures and
different tools
for projects in sport pharma e-commerce
and marketing
my presentation today will consist by
three parts first one we'll cover
general topics that were related to data
pipelines uh second part will be about
aws services and last one we will get
familiar with different architectures
implemented on aws
okay
if you are running modern business most
likely you considered hiring a data
scientist
later times the data scientists can do
some descriptive analysis orchid can
train machine learning models uh for
improving customer experience or
fraud detection doing sentiment analysis
but data pipeline is a crucial part
piece of this puzzle but what is the
data pipeline
here you see just a simple schema of
data pipeline
this one is a source
the place where we are getting raw data
we have intermediate
steps processing steps operation one
operation two and three and they can be
more operations this just for example
and last one is a
target the place where data getting
loaded when it's already processed
just a brief definition of data pipeline
it's a series of steps that move raw
data from source to the destination
and
we have
and
let's talk about what kind of source we
can have actually sources can be
different it can be a relational
database like mysql or osql it can be
crm or salesforce
ethereum such as salesforce or hubspot
actually you can just send a request to
api and receive this data even it was a
simple cases when data provider uploaded
csv files on on the cloud like s3 and we
just pulled it and after started
processing
regarding pro and processing step
actually it consists by different steps
one is transformation another one is
energy augmentation or enrichment
filtering grouping aggregation let's
focus on each of the of them
first one is filtering filtering can
consist by different steps for example
also it's based on the business rules
for example four numbers right
some columns should cos have only
positive numbers not negatives some some
call some values cannot be less than
zero or larger than some specific
threshold it can be provided by business
or it can be just naturally
for example
yeah weather cannot be
like larger maybe one than one plus one
thousand or minus one thousand it's
theoretically possible but in a real
case it's
uh another place for example for
filtering uh when in my ca there was a
project when data probably expected from
data providers some text based on the
keyword but data provider sent a lot of
noisy data and we use this kind of
filtering to remove noise because this
noise noise later
made a problem for machine learning
teams
and this is very important to do high
quality filtering
to help machine learning teams to have
less problems let's say so
filtering possible by keyword or by
context
it's more advanced way when you train
machine learning model to understand the
context of the string and filter
by the
by the context
what's interesting that you have to
collect statistics about
about filtered data
how much data you filtered out and how
much remained
why it's important first that a later
you will ask your data provider that
your data struggle and you're providing
noisy data and you can exactly so on
which place it failed it was text or it
was numbers and so on like different
validation steps and you're collecting
statistics about
that
validation rules
transformation actually from
transformation side it can be just a
change in a date date format
a few days ago for example one of my
clients asked to change the date time
format to uk format i didn't know that
it was some difference but it was also
dictated by business rules
they can be for example transformation
in text just
changing from lower case to upper case
also very important to handle null
values
people getting confused that sometimes
people thinking that null values is
zeros they are not zeros
you think you should think about null
values are unknown
and it's
also task specific how you will handle
them sometimes you can put maximum value
or mean value sometimes you have to have
it as it is like just have null values
augmentation this is enrichment part for
example you have coordinates latitude
and longitude and based on this
coordinates you can know also about
country city maybe altitude we analyzed
that um
track and field data and we
we knew about
coordinates of the venue when this
championship happened and based on this
we started collecting information about
weather to know
at least performance during different
weather conditions
and we were we were able to do this
uh using this only two longitude and
latitude just imagine having two to
these columns we were able to make our
data sets very rich and help data
analyst team to
took some cool analysis and yes try to
find some interesting insight in the
data
another possible way for enrichment data
enrichment
they're just extracting day of the week
the week of the year from your dates you
can make it more informative
and later these aggregations can be run
also on this kind of specific data maybe
weekday it was weekend or working day
and this kind of nuances it's all
related to enrichment part actually
grouping and aggregation
in case of grouping in the column you
have a lot of different groups
you can just aggregate them together and
have total value or average value
and all of this is processing steps and
destination this is a place
where our prepared data getting loaded
it can be data lake or data warehouse it
also depends
that we will consider both of types how
we can implement them on a stream
actually this is three stages
and
uh people quite frequently get confused
what's the difference between etl and
data pipeline actually etl is a sub-type
of data pipeline
data pipeline don't necessarily
transform the data
in case of vtl we have extract
transformed load three stages in case of
data pipeline it can be just move data
from a to b like one
um it can be
moving data from one database to another
database or yeah it's not necessary to
run transformation operation
second one is data pipeline don't
necessarily finish after loading data in
case of etl it runs and ends like it's
one-time job
extracting transforming loading loading
to the database and that's all that's
done
in case of data pipeline they also can
be a real-time analytics platform like
streaming data it's and events come
continuously
we are receiving it without stopping
okay
different um
examples like for example you are
monitoring bitcoin price
or you are running something like google
analytics you are receiving these online
events
from the web page
and yeah this streaming and
third one is data pipeline don't
necessarily run in batches
as i said before like etl in case of etl
during some time data getting collected
and
it'll run in on scheduled pages like in
the end of day or maybe during the
weekends when we collected a lot of data
we are running etl to process it
uh
yeah in case of streaming data like it's
not running on interval it's learning
continuously
and
we
during my presentation i want to
talk about three type of architectures
uh
data pipeline architectures first one is
page-based data pipeline second one
streaming data pipeline pipeline and
third one is the lambda architecture
let's continue let's talk about each one
briefly and
what is the differ and see what's the
difference
okay
page-based data pipeline actually as i
said before data getting collected
during some interval
and we are running
our atl on schedule it based like
end of the day or weekends and example
and the use case of this kind of
page data pipeline can be
imaging you are running your shop on
shopify and you are collecting your
transactions
people paying or
transactions can consist payments or
refunds or different
situations a cancellation or card
expired and all of these transactions
getting collected during the day
in the end by the end of the day you are
running your etl to process all of these
transactions
and
load this data data
data to the data warehouse where further
data analytics team can do different
kind of analysis like customer churn
prediction or it can be customer
lifetime value all of these metrics can
can be calculated but to make it
possible first you have to load the data
in pre-prepared way to the data
warehouse
actually
this is about page-based data pipeline
we already talked about streaming data
pipeline
the way when
even it's also known as event streaming
you are receiving this data continuously
for example i had one project it's kind
of
deploying infrastructure in for in-house
google analytics kind of in google
analytics
and each action each interaction of the
user on the website we try to collect
each interaction of the user
and
this is example how this can be
implemented like user clicks or user
moves mouse and we are receiving these
events
and it's kind of it comes to the kinesis
first and after kind of this move we
moved it to the
there was actually two places to move
one to the data lake to have a raw data
and another one it we moved it to the
elasticsearch and after we had kibano
kibana for monitoring live events
uh two purposes sometimes you want to
know
that they kind of speed layer we will
discard it during lambda architecture
and you want to know something quickly
but you also want to have raw data
because machine learning team can use it
to train machine learning models for
different purposes
actually this is about streaming data
pipelines and
third one
is a lambda architecture
a lambda architecture combines both
pitch data pipeline and streaming data
pipeline you see two options of lambda
architecture we have data source
real-time layer also it's called speed
layer
and patch layer and they're getting they
that they're getting combined in the
serving layer
serving layer just think about about
some database like mongodb for example
where data getting indexed
another option it's lambda but you have
as a serving layers
so you have separate serving layers
here is a one serving layer the and in
the second case there are separate
serving layers
one of the problems with lambda that you
have to have
two
text tags like two stacks one for batch
processing and another one for stream
processing
and maintaining this kind of
infrastructure can be can get
problematic on enterprise level also
your data should be synchronized like
when you have this in
separate yeah you
in case of some problems
in the future you can see some mismatch
between the data
actually yeah this is a problem of
lambda there is another one is com gap
by architecture which is bitten new
really really
comparing with lambda i will not cover
it here but actually
the goal of the kappa to have one stake
instead of two stakes
and this kind of simplified version of
lambda architecture
here i covered three different
architectures of data pipelines it's
batch it's streaming and lambda
and now i want to talk about aw aws
services that i personally use during my
data engineering projects
okay you see the list of s aw services
maybe it's overloading here but i
especially did it if someone want to
take a picture and know about heavy
services but actually the first one is
uh s3 or simple storage service
by aws it enables users to store and
three
data at any time at any scale
what
you can create your data
lakes on s3 actually
s3 allows storing
structured and structured
semi-structured data in different
formats
they also different storage classes for
s3 it if you're going to use your data
frequently the infrequent storage class
actually when you are putting your data
on s3 it stores it in three different
availability zones but
for cost optimization you can have it
like you can choose
if one's only frequent
access class this will store um
this will reduce your cost but be aware
that there's some risk related to these
kind of decisions
second one athena which is interactive
query
query service actually you can use
standard sql uh to analyze the files
that you stored on s3 in your data lake
and the ways to optimize were
athena
one
actually let's let's do this way athena
allows
supports different types of file it can
be
csv json avro or also column oriented
data files like parkit or orc
it's recommended to use a column
oriented file to optimize athena
actually i stored my files in a packet
format
also
it's recommended to compress your files
for example you make it in jazzy format
in that way you will reduce uh the size
of the files it will uh uh actually it
will affect on the price
and also
you know this will improve i think um
actually it will improve working process
of having less define it this way
also partitioning very important
when you create when you put in data on
s3 it's possible also to create a set of
buckets you also can create folders and
with these folders you can do
partitioning what's the partitioning
like you can have folders uh structure
like year month and date even hour
and you do this way now think about like
you're writing select something from the
files and you can filter out anything
that not related
to your query like
you want to get data only from january
or march and with partitioning you will
eliminate extra data
but it is why is good because
uh affinity charge charge five dollars
per terabyte of scant data
and there are also extra charges
actually what interesting we say
extra charges but quite quick
quite frequently these extra charges
make large build for you
actually a few times ago i run projects
i i just checked pricing pages of aws it
was nice but after two days i got a 500
bill that i didn't expect and it
described that my
projects pro budget
actually be very careful we say that was
pricing even there is aws calculator you
can use but you need to be a bit skilled
to understand all the details otherwise
be aware that charges can be very large
okay in case of affine optimization we
say target format compression
partitioning and actually better to have
with larger files instead of having
a lot of small smooth files just combine
them together
maybe a few megabytes instead of having
a few kilobytes of data okay
this is about athena
lambda which is server-less event-driven
compute service
actually what's good in lambda that it
supports docker
and
i dockerize some of my projects
and just push it to an elastic container
registry this is something like docker
hub on the aws
and you can
configure your lambda to use your docker
image
that exists on hcr
and
this kind of tricky way to reduce your
cost is when
if i'm not wrong lambda provides 1
million
runs for free during the month and
imagine you are on startup you need to
save your some money
in data collection from different
sources like google ads or facebook ads
you can schedule your lambda to run
on scheduled way like every day or every
four hours
and pull this data from facebook or
somewhere and load to database without
spending money because it's like you
have
some space for running it for free
and this is kind of tricks that you can
run if you want to also save money
dynamodb it's fully managed serverless
key value database
in case of dynamodb i
we i had a case when we passed the
athlete's
web page and each athlete had a unique
id
and i used id as a key
and in the value i just start json
information about which part page we
already passed and this kind of metadata
about athlete this kind of one example
how you can you use key value store
yeah key values database
rds uh relational database system
service uh collection of our database
services it can be amazon abroad with
mysql compatibility
postgresql compatibility mysql mariadb
postgresql
but good is with rds that you can easily
deploy your cluster in multiple uh
availability zones
very quickly
and also
set back making backups to make a backup
you just need to configure
a few configuration and it will
automatically start making
backups as well like it's quite fast
to run your cluster database cluster
with rds but still be aware about
pricing can you assess because you are
running clustering different
availability zones and poor moving data
between different availability zones or
even regions
yeah there is this kind of
new assets that you should
take into account
redshift which the data fully managed
data warehouse
it's able to
actually store data from 100 gigabytes
to beta bytes of data
um if you want to run a little
analytical database just consider
redshift
uh elastic mapreduce is it provides big
data platform
um we said emr eukarya for example your
app actually spark spark cluster or hive
actually i run spark cluster it takes
just a few clicks to make your cluster
ready
and what's good with emr that there's
two options one with a step jobs and
another one is jupiter notebook i think
most of you use jupiter notebook to just
do some analysis quickly same it's
possible to do with spark cluster but
not only a few megabytes of data but
gigabytes of data but the same way you
have a jupiter notebook you're loading
this from s3 and running your analysis
with spark
it's quite comfortable and easy and when
you are already
when you have a code and you are done
you can make your code you can move your
code to the python script
and after use step jobs what is a step
job
you have a pipeline and one of the
processes one of the process is run your
spark cluster right to process the big
data
and for that you don't need to have your
cluster running 24 hours
if we step jobs you can say okay run
cluster
when you need it run cluster
make this calculation
store it somewhere and terminate your
cluster that's all with this way you
will save money and
yeah you can do it quickly without
running your cluster 24 hours
glue which is etl extract from the etl
service
actually
it's for data cataloging
imaging you have a
what it does you have a lot of files on
s3 and clearance is a crawler and it
goes through your files first understand
the file of data it can be cr says csv
or json
and after it
try to scan schema predict schema
understand properties
and in the end you have metadata about
your data
with this way the glue has you can
create tables and you can use these
tables to run queries from afina
but not only from affine
data pipeline this is another service
that allows moving data from different
aws services
between two different aws services
we will see difference between glue and
data pipeline on the next slide
kinesis which is several streaming data
services that make it easy to capture
process
and store data streams at any scale
actually kinesis there is a four kinesis
services
one for video streaming for uh another
one for data streaming capturing data
streams uh
from in parallel from thousands of
services and gigabytes of data
another one data
data horse firefox the kinesis firehose
which is streaming etl service
and what's cool that from firehose you
can
store your data on
s3 or in your data warehouse immediately
like you're receiving data in kinesis
from kinesis you're configuring data
firehose and from firehose
one you can run two fire hose one that
stores data on s3 another one that
stores data on redshift
actually this is uh architecture that we
implemented
for the project
and
a stream and last one is the kinesis
stream analytics service that allows
using standard sql for running queries
on your streaming stream data
last one is step function which is
serverless orchestration service it
allows to orchestrate workflows based on
aws services
okay this will be the large
slide
actually what we covered now we know
about three type
we know about three type of pipelines
watch batch base pipeline stream is a
streaming pipeline lambda pipeline
we know about aws services used for
data engineering now time to combine
these two type of knowledge together
and see how we can implement these
architectures that can be used in the
further for your projects as well
but ah first let's uh briefly what's the
difference between glue and data
pipeline
glue is serverless
and also glue support provides support
for the
skyline python
opposite to the glue a data pipeline
provides support for the wall uh tools
that exist in the emr it can be hive
spark and so on
and title pipeline is not serverless
when you're running data pipeline you
have to pay
not only for pipelines but of all the
related sources that really uh
to your pipeline in case of aws glue
it's running in apache spark framework
environment sorry
and it's
it's called the data processing unit
the and it built for every second of use
like this a difference here you don't
care about server side
but here you have more access
to manage your
infrastructure but you also need a
different kind of skills to do it
think about these two services aws glue
for cataloging data cataloging and aws
data pipeline for data
trans
no traffic
transferring sorry
for data transferring and data
cataloging i had a case when i used aws
data pipeline when i needed to move
data from dynamodb i wanted to have
backup of dynamod
db data on s3 and for that purposes i
use data pipeline
another case for aws glue data provider
uploaded a lot of data on s3 and we
needed to
quickly read this data
and provide it actually you can read
this data and put to a machine learning
model
and that was a
using apache aws glue we were able to
implement this solution
this is a difference between glue and
data pipeline
okay
this is one of the architectures that
possible to implement on aws here's the
links if you want to play with this or
even with cloud formation you can
quickly have this infrastructure and
play with this
uh
s3 we already talked about it we have a
ah what's the problem
you are working as a data engineer and
client says
um
now your manager says okay client want
to provide data as a csv file they don't
have api
just uploading on s3
new data engineer and we want to get it
ready on in our database how you will
implement it
data getting loaded on s3 bucket
and it's possible to trigger lambda when
someone when data uploaded on s3
and this triggers lambda and lambda us
our
step functions this pipeline what
happens next first is validation
remember validation is a crucial without
validation probably you will provide
this data to machine learning team with
a lot of problems and after them they
will have problems and after doing a
call every one staff will start blaming
each other what the why we stuck with
deadlines
validated carefully have accurate data
this is important
here we are validating data if there is
errors
we are putting it in error folder
when we put it in error folder actually
this icon of sns service simple
notification service is a low sending
notification
send notification to engineer or anyone
who is taking out ownership
for this project and notify that this
error
if it's okay run in schema uh glue
crawler this understand the scheme of
the file
and creates metastar meta
table for it running transformation we
already discussed it
making it park it format
optimized for running with afina
also partitioning it and compressing and
why we have second crawler because we
changed our data format like after
transfer transformation enrichment our
data become became a bit different and
we need to run it second time this is
one
architecture uh that you can experiment
and
second one for real-time streaming
analytics is called a real-time
streaming analytics pipeline
imaging you are creating google
analytics platform for you a user
interacts with the web page you are
receiving events
it clicks and you are receiving it
actually here also can be load balancer
and because a lot of requests come in
and after this load balancer puts these
events to the amazon kinetic amazon
kinesis
from kinesis
you can
using firehose you are putting raw data
on s3
this can be used in the future because
also why it's important to have raw data
because during transformation different
step of transformation there can be some
problems with raw data you can also make
debugging easier you have raw data and
you run it manually and see what
happened in the intermediate steps
with raw data after we are using kines
analytics and lambda actually here i
would change my approach was just using
firehose to put it in elasticsearch and
i had kibana for monitoring
here it's another way like they're
analyzing it and sending a notification
for example even bitcoin
reach some price you are receiving a
notification if you are trader and
trading bitcoin
this is streaming data pipeline and also
here is a link if you want to play with
this
actually we have a few minutes this is
different kind of architectures you can
take image if you need
and aws patch that i wanted to mention
during my talk it's a
large scale
computation service
imaging you want to parse web page and
it has very complex structure
that you need to click fade click wait i
think data loaded and which way you can
do this um
which way i did it i created this parser
we're using also selenium for after
making these steps after dockerized it
and pushed on ecr elastic content
registry
with aws page there is a queue where you
can put your jobs
and also you can defer to make a job
definition that it use
that image that you created and run
these parsing commands
now think this way you are putting links
and it's each web page link as a job
and you have a queue
and you have also your cluster and it
started processing
um and this way you can process hundreds
and hundred thousand of web pages in
parallel also it depends on your budget
but
one
tip that i actually what i figured out
working with aws patch that you don't
need to create very
short jobs like few second job or 10
second job because transition between
job steps
is getting bit lower better to create
patch
put patch of urls for the one job in
this case you will parsing one job will
take more than one minute and for aws
page also it gets okay but
few second jobs it's not
actually it will work but yeah their
cluster will run longer
better to make
a bunch of um parts of your list to put
as a one job
with this way i was able to parse
hundreds of thousand web pages in just a
few hours even less than one hour also
it depends on the size of your cluster
because it's this run in parallel
actually yeah i've i
finished my presentation thank you very
much for listening leave us the links
uh if you have questions
no it's time for questions
yeah thank you very much for the great
talk you mentioned that you
if i understood correctly you expose
sometimes you expose the s3 bucket to
your data providers in order for them to
upload the data how do you do it
actually
actually it's possible to configure
permissions when your pro
it's single url or how it's called
actually we can like we can talk about
after presentation but it's possible to
configure permissions that a client has
access only to the specific packet and
they're uploading it to the bucket so
client needs to be on aws as well right
so
the client needs to have an account and
you expose the permissions for for the
concrete account i don't remember it
exactly because i i don't have complete
ownership on our aws account
but at least yes you can provide access
with some limits at least you can create
user in aws account and make some
restricted restrictions
in the rules at least this possible but
i think there is also second option that
we can check thank you
by the way what if
interesting situation happened data
provider after having conflict with
management removed all the data that you
uploaded on s3 and better to have copies
of this data
be careful also yeah
any other questions
thank you let's say the data provider
uses excel
uh what should be done in that case
let's say it should the data be put in
uh google sheets and read in that way or
what would you do actually for example
the simple case when you're using pandas
there's option to read as you're reading
csv also you can read excel file
and that's absolutely not a problem but
very very
important to ask your data provider to
provide in the expected format because
sometimes they creating this exam is a
very fancy structure with some
visualizations and it's getting hard
just saying okay we're expecting in this
format
this column names for example and that's
all like they should upload it in the
expected format
you can provide him some example file
like some sample file
yeah sorry it's me again uh so you
mentioned the
the fire fire horse right so the thing
that uh like gets data from kinesis and
puts it to a three
um do you know if uh if it's
like does it just put the the files to
s3 without any partitioning or you can
configure some kind of partition
yeah like for example if you want to
partition your data like by date or by
hour or by some contents of their
records do you know what's good if it's
possible or not
i can't tell exactly about that if
firehose can do it but it's possible
definitely to conv to bind a lambda
function to firehose and it goes from
high force to lambda function and it
actually runs this partitioning
because i remember when i put my data to
elasticsearch it was in the middle was
lambda that beat the chain transferred
our data and after put it on
elasticsearch and same way you can
partition it
[Applause]